[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Álvaro cordero
Este próximo 20 de noviembre catar se
convertirá en la primera nación de medio
oriente en acoger un mundial de fútbol
un evento sin precedentes que sin
embargo ha levantado numerosas polémicas
en torno a los motivos por los que esta
pequeña nación ha sido elegida como sede
de un acontecimiento deportivo tan
importante y debido a las denuncias de
numerosas ong por las violaciones a los
Derechos Humanos que comete este país es
por ello que en France 24 queremos
brindarles algo de contexto sobre esta
nación y sus orígenes
Qatar está situado en una pequeña
península unida a la Península arábiga
su tamaño apenas llega a la mitad del
que tiene El Salvador la nación más
pequeña de América continental en este
espacio totalmente desértico viven 2,6
millones de personas de las cuales solo
unas 300.000 son cataríes el resto son
trabajadores migrantes que en su mayoría
se encargan de proveer servicios y ser
mano de obra datos que hacen decatar una
nación pequeña en términos demográficos
y territoriales algo que no ha impedido
que sea una potencia regional
para entender esto hay que mirar su
historia
Qatar está gobernada desde mediados del
siglo 19 por la familia altane sin
embargo durante siglos fue un territorio
clave en la venta de perlas bajo
influencia de varios imperios como el
persa o el otomano la situación cambio a
partir de 1916 cuando pasó a ser un
protectorado británico aunque los altani
siguieron teniendo un poder político
dentro del territorio fue bajo este
protectorado cuando Reino Unido
descubrió en sus exploraciones grandes
cantidades de petróleo y de gas natural
dos elementos que convertirían acatar en
una pieza fundamental en la economía
mundial en 1961 el territorio pasó a
formar parte de la OPEP la Organización
de Países exportadores de petróleo tan
solo un año después de conformarse esta
organización y en 1971 este territorio
se convirtió por primera vez en un
estado independiente tras este proceso
catarse conformó como una monarquía
absoluta de corte conservador donde la
religión juega un papel fundamental
los alta ni crearon un emirato en el que
el wahabismo una rama integrista del
sunismo que defiende el lado más
tradicional del islam tiene un papel muy
importante en sus leyes en Qatar están
prohibidos los partidos políticos y los
sindicatos el poder reside
mayoritariamente en el Emir y en su
entorno el cual pertenece también a la
familia altani este país tiene una
legislación que por ejemplo castiga con
cárcel y persigue la homosexualidad que
prohíbe a las mujeres conducir un
automóvil o que fomenta el trabajo
esclavo de migrantes a través de un
sistema tradicional llamado cafala
puntos que sin embargo contrastan con su
cercanía a occidente desde la década de
1990 Qatar ha sido socio de Naciones
como Estados Unidos e incluso ha
participado en operaciones militares
conjuntas como en la guerra del Golfo de
1990 contra Irak o en la invasión alivia
en 2011 su política económica neoliberal
y también se diferencia de su tradición
religiosa algo que ha llevado a doha su
capital a convertirse en un centro
urbano de los más modernos del planeta
su poder se debe básicamente a la gran
cantidad de combustibles fósiles que
posee esta pequeña nación en este mapa
podemos observar todas las bolsas de gas
y petróleo que tiene Qatar en su
territorio y especialmente en su zona
marítima esta nación es el tercer mayor
exportador de gas natural del mundo Al
poseer el 13% del total global y además
tiene una reserva de unos 25 mil
millones de barriles de petróleo para
las próximas décadas una fortaleza que
esta pequeña nación ha sabido aprovechar
para aumentar su influencia en el mundo
árabe y en el resto del planeta un
ejemplo es su canal de Noticias al
jazeera una cadena de televisión que es
la más vista en medio oriente y que
proyecta la visión catari hacia multitud
de países además varios fondos soberanos
han invertido en numerosas empresas de
todo el mundo llegando a poseer equipos
de fútbol como el París Saint Germain o
reconocidas compañías aéreas una forma
de poder blando que tiene una influencia
muy alta
esta situación ha llegado a preocupar
incluso Arabia Saudita el actor
internacional más fuerte del Golfo
Pérsico en 2017 este país junto a otras
monarquías árabes de la zona como
emiratos árabes Unidos o bahrein
iniciaron un bloqueo económico y
político contra Qatar por promocionar y
financiar a grupos terroristas como
estadio islámico algo que han hecho
personas privadas de Qatar pero que
también lo han hecho de Arabia Saudita y
por su cercanía también con Irán el
máximo rival de riad este gesto hizo
temer un conflicto en la región y el
futuro de Qatar Aunque en 2021 las
relaciones volvieron a normalizarse
después de que este aislamiento no
impidiera que el emirato catari siguiera
creciendo
en este contexto celebrar un mundial de
fútbol es un ejemplo más de la capacidad
que puede llegar a tener Qatar Gracias a
todos sus recursos y una oportunidad
para reivindicarse frente a las otras
naciones árabes las denuncias que ha
recibido por parte de ongs como amnistía
internacional o human Rise watch por sus
leyes que atacan algunos derechos
humanos y que castigan especialmente a
la comunidad lgbti o por las condiciones
infrahumanas que han vivido trabajadores
migrantes para construir las
instalaciones del mundial no han servido
para que la FIFA suspenda este evento y
esto es otra muestra de su poder en las
próximas semanas se verá si su
influencia es efectiva una vez que el
balón echa a rodar o si este mundial
quedará manchado por los escándalos que
lo rodean con esto concluimos Gracias
por compartir y comentar estas historias
que las encuentran en los programas de
France 24.com
[Música]